okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today
we are talking about
the rational male aka rola tomasi
and michaela peterson
before i start you know you already know
what i'm gonna say if you have watched
two or more of my videos two or more of
my lives two or more of my reels and you
don't subscribe
me you we have what we have what beef
beef okay
okay
um
so what are
we talking about today so
i've been reacting i've been live like
pretty much all day i've been reacting
to
rollo and michaela go back and forth
basically
rola tomasi made a video on michaela
peterson a couple months back
and what what did he say about her
he used her life as an example to
demonstrate
what happens when women go through he
calls it like the making up for missing
out
the kill to party dynamic basically okay
when us women get married young
i'm gonna let you call in in a second
okay when us women get married young we
see all of our friends going out having
a good time we're like dang
or have a kid young
we're like dang
dang
that looks fun but i gotta stay home
with the kids right
so what happens is a lot of times once
the kid is old enough to like
you know like be on its own whatever
um
then
i'm gonna copy that
then
they leave the baby daddy later
because they feel like they could have
died did better basically
now
rolo was using michaela i might have
butchered that a little bit but rolo was
using michaela peterson as an example he
said basically she got pregnant young it
was an accident you know like
oops my bad
i don't know um she went off birth
control this dude got her knocked up
okay she was like 22.
so she has her kid
is with him not with him ish for like
five years
you know on and off basically during
this on and off period but she's still
legally married
ma'am
the woman is posting bikini shots
she's got her stomach out which is very
flat she's a good-looking girl i'm not
going to take that away from you
it appears like she's partying but she
claims she wasn't partying the whole
time but
then then she gets flown out
by the one and only andrew tate now
andrew tate is an international playboy
he has videos on his channel talking
about how he hooks up with his
girlfriends in front of each other
this man
he's like managed women for like
campsites or something i don't really
know
he flew her out she claims we did
nothing sexual he claims they did
nothing sexual but it was just a little
weird considering you know
she had a man i'm technically married
but she said that was like during an off
period because they were on and off
and at the same time during all this
her dad the great
jordan peterson's in the hospital but it
seems like that happened like right
after i don't i don't know the timeline
on things whatever
so then
after jordan peterson gets better
she is divorcing her husband and now
she magically found god right at the age
of 29. now what what happens at 29 as
women we go through our epiphany phase
we basically it's like um rollo
i'm butchering this these are all
rollers ideas basically our epiphany
phase like women find god because
they're basically trying to like
re-market themselves as like wife
material and like be like look all that
partying in my 20s
forget about that
forget about that whoops
my bad just forget about the last decade
um
[Music]
now conveniently right when i need a
husband i found
god
how convenient is that
ma'am now
rolla doesn't deny that they may have
feel those feelings right
he doesn't deny that
it's just mad convenient
so now what does she do
she dates younger she has a new
christian boyfriend who's 23 he's dating
a single mom
and
he's a lot younger than her
and but this kind of goes with rolos
theory because he says like these single
moms date younger men because those men
like don't typically have as many
options as like the older ones who like
know better than to date single moms
okay
now the question is during okay so now
where where's the debate where did rolla
possibly go through too far
rollo did a live stream where
he compared
he he's using michaela
as an archetype for these theories so
the making up for missing out
and one of the theories or the
he doesn't call it a theory he says it's
a
practicality i forgot what he calls it
but one of the theories or one of his
tenets
is it's it's a kill to party dynamic and
he uses casey anthony as an example he
also uses brittany renner
my dad's calling should i answer
um i'll i'll tell him i'll call him back
later um he also uses casey anthony and
brittany renner basically like girls
that had kids younger than they wanted
those kids were kind of a buzz kill like
they killed their party that they're
gonna have
they're gonna have like a little fun
you know
and it's just like mad and convenient
these children
now
now
michaela is saying
you don't have a right to compare me to
casey anthony even though even though
during his live stream when he talks
about this rolo said a million times he
said i am not saying that michaela
peterson
wanted to kill her kid or wishes her kid
doesn't exist this is just the same
dynamic
it killed the kids killed the party
earlier
michaela says
and she's sassy with it she is
she is like
i would never compare someone to someone
who murdered their kid
i
love my daughter okay thank you very
much for the super chat we're at 180 of
the thousand dollar super chat goal that
is going towards equipment for the new
the pre-game podcast that is coming out
hopefully in a couple weeks
my sound board is late i'm very
irritated about it but we're not going
to worry about that
okay
um
i'm gonna put the link in the chat
and we could talk about it
now
the pregame is going to be very hype
remember guys hot women
the pregame podcast sounds like a pretty
good idea it's gonna be a great idea hot
do you guys like attractive women in
college
that are a little bit less [ __ ] than
freshly fit like not as nuts
okay i don't have a trust fund yet
hopefully i mean like
i don't know at some point look it right
now i have nothing so don't let's not go
there
okay
do you guys like hot women
donate
hot women hot girls
and a couple guys it's gonna be like
ecology atmosphere it's gonna be very
fun okay
now
being latina i want a latina on the show
i'll find you one donate i'll find you a
latina
um okay now we got i'm gonna see if i
can ever pin it from stream labs for
whatever reason
did he take it too far
was the question
um
where is
college women are not that great well
some are okay
well they're in there most of them are
in the masters program yeah 11 likes and
29 views guys a like is free a like is
free
free what are you doing all right call
in though i'm gonna see if i can pin the
the live stream
latinas are away okay i thought that's
his spam i don't i don't know i don't
okay
um
let me put i'm gonna pin the live stream
in the chat
um
[Music]
pin
okay
[Music]
hi matt
it's uh
been an interesting day but uh how are
you doing
good how are you
uh good i did a lot of running around
today it was kind of wild uh also
anyway it's all over now but uh
okay so you think it was too far why um
well i don't
i guess it
it was too far i guess
if it depends on the audience if you're
like
well no you're you're the you're the
audience
okay
yeah yeah i mean like
i guess you kind of know how i am i'd
say a lot of stuff and a lot of it's
pretty aggressive but like i i expect a
pushback
but like that's the only thing where
it's like i'm kind of like kind of
shocked i'm like i think like rose like
trying to like um browbeat like uh
mckayla peterson to like not being
offended it's like
i don't
think that's how it really works like
say what you want but people want to
take it
how's it's going to be communicated
and
if that makes kind of uh any sense i
don't know if it's just rambling but
no i don't understand what you're saying
you're saying he doesn't want michaela
to be offended yeah i think he's like
well i don't think he cares if she's
offended like at all
well i mean then what was i i was
um
working and stuff but what was like most
of the his recent video about then yeah
because i doubt it was fully about just
that whole situation
um i think rollo is very like he always
says the same thing like do you want to
be happy or do you want to be right
something to that effect so i think he's
just trying to prove that he's right
in terms of like the
um like for example
i'm sorry
um well for example one of the things
that he said was that um
that like she said that she doesn't do
that with thumbnails and that's like one
of the things he talked about today was
she had like some click baity moment
where she said
i i would never compare someone to
anything like in thumbnails like you're
like i would never use clickbaity
thumbnail some something along those
lines i'm butchering it right and he's
just so he's like pulling up the
thumbnails and saying like you you
literally do
like yeah
so it's like stuff like that i don't i
think if he cared about her being
offended he probably wouldn't have done
that whole podcast where he didn't
apologize like once
or
twice anything she said
well i know that she's been she has her
own podcast and
and i understand it like you know get
what gets clicks but it's like you can't
and this is not um criticism towards you
in particular but like you know whatever
comes along with that like hey if
cnn says like
you're blah blah blah i mean it is what
it is at that point
so that's really like what i don't
understand what you're saying it's kind
of like uh kind of what i saw was that
like you know roll kind of made the
comparison i thought it was a little
i usually don't like talking things to
do with like other people's kids or
they're
good i think
i mean if you go if you do that that's
fine just expect a lot of blow back
uh but i was just kind of saying like
okay if you kind of have like a certain
thumbnail like um
i'm not going to name names because
they're not exactly here to defend them
and
i don't want to kind of muddy the
platform probably more than i did today
but you know certain people will kind of
do like someone dies or
um
something pretty sad happens so i'll
have like a really goofy thumbnail
because that that's what gives me likes
but it's like
well we're talking about the thumbnail
he made so he made a thumbnail with
michaela peterson and um the playboy guy
um
what's his face uh andrew tate so okay
case casey anthony wasn't even in the
thumbnail yeah it was insane so she was
so she was going on the roommates and
saying oh you make
a thumbnail comparing me to casey
anthony but she casey anthony wasn't
even in the thumbnail
that's been awesome so like what she was
saying wasn't even wasn't even true yeah
and then the second thing that he went
over um
because i think like casey anthony and
brittany runner they're just both
examples of a dynamic that he talks
about and he like said over and over and
over again that
like i'm not saying she wants to kill
her kid i'm not saying it's the same
thing it's just the same dynamic yeah
and so so my point of view is that
if he says that
like it's very clear he's not implying
that she wants like the kid to be gone
do you think that's do you think that's
wrong or do you think that's right
oh you disagree
i think kind of
uh thinking okay so it wasn't in a
thumbnail because i
i would be uh
i think it was a if it wasn't a
thumbnail there probably would have been
a far bigger [ __ ] storm than it is but i
think even for i guess for off it must
have been like an offhand comparison or
not even comparison i mentioned less
than that it's still like uh but
i honestly if i was him
but i i don't i think it's easy for me
to say but i would just kind of not just
mention that uh
brittany comparison sasha mentioned sure
it's just like
especially i guess when you're dealing
with her um uh maternity uh
uh her having a child and something
being mother
kind of i feel like comparing it to uh
just mentioning uh casey answers like
kind of nuclear but that's just
so i i i get that he's not trying to say
like yeah
like
killed
so you think it was too far even though
he clarified that this is not
to say that she wants to kill her child
this is not to say like even though he
like made it very clear you would still
say that's too far i just want to say
understand
well
i don't think it's like a huge like mark
against its character i just think it's
kind of like a a bit of a unfortunately
an unforced error if you kind of have to
go back and explain that or not you can
just be like hey y'all it wasn't that
deep it's kind of an other option
but it's it's kind of and it's so hard
especially during a live stream and you
know i disagree with them with a lot of
things why i completely understand you
have so many things going on in your
head and just trying to get it down
it's really easy to trip up but it's
it's like
uh
it's it's
[Music]
yeah so it probably came off like really
aggressive earlier but it wasn't like
well i i wasn't really reading the
comments too closely so i don't really
know what you're talking about but um
i just i just want um i just want a yes
or no answer so you would say yes it was
too far that's your answer
yeah
um
okay
all right
that's fine i don't think he went in
with like bad intentions i don't know
i'm not saying like oh yeah
i just think like it was kind of like a
little bit of a public uh relationship
uh
that's really how i see it
okay
yeah for me i would say that
i think if he clarified like 10 times
during the whole thing i i think it's
like pretty clear he wasn't saying that
yeah i can see i can see where you're
coming from but i just i don't agree
with you
yeah unfortunately we live in kind of
like the clip era and i i get it's like
a live stream kind of like a community
chat and stuff but it's live streams
like um
i believe that one was roughly
uh
uh two hours or so
if someone was just like hopping in and
there and they hurt that it could have
been like oh but i don't know i actually
like just don't
i haven't watched the stream and i've
know if i thought i'd find a little bit
awkward go back and watch live streams i
just watched them live if i do that so
okay well thank you for calling in
appreciate it
no problems finally got a friend
i'll talk to you next time
all right guys
um
okay guys what do you think
um he says too far too far
no matter no matter how many times you
clarify you
the kids involved
you're bringing the kid into it
no sir
no
sir
but let me know i could be wrong call
me in
or what call me it call it
um
maybe it's not slander the casey anthony
slander was hilarious what it wasn't
about the kid it was about the dynamic
i agree
i agree um
do you guys think it would have been
better if she just was like yep
i was partying and just didn't deny it
at all
um
are you and torsha gonna back up donovan
sharp and if i said donovan going in a
fight i did not hear anything
um
guys call in call in call in
she didn't kill the kid but she did kill
the family oh
that's good
i am under the impression that there's
more than one reason to get divorced i
don't think that it's simply like
i don't think it's like as simple as
her
hypergamy
made her leave but i do think it was
more like
i guess she probably was looking for a
better match
but i don't know i don't think there's
like
sometimes people
really just are not meant to be together
you ever go to that friend's house and
their parents were like always fighting
um
call in call in
oh my goodness
i would love
also guys
you already know i'm about to plug it if
you've been watching for a minute what
am i saving for new equipment i need a
new sound board and four new mics
to get to the number of mics that i want
for this podcast what is the podcast
it's going to be called
the pre-game at pearls or with pearl i
don't actually know but
what is it going to be it's going to be
girls from my college talking about
different relationship dynamics it's
going to be less ratchet
than like fresh and fit
like all the like crazy stuff
um which is kind of funny because
rolo definitely made a thing today that
was like everyone wants to do it but
better i'm like
look
i'd say better just different
um and it's gonna have a couple guys one
or two guys
um i think the perfect amount of people
is like six or seven so that's what i'd
really like six or seven people
anyways consider donating if you've
watched a couple of my streams but i
really need people to talk to
y'all
call in call in
okay yay
hello
hi pearl
hi how are you
this is john
hi john have you called him before
yeah like a couple times before
okay um so what's your stance do you
think he took it too far yes or no
no i don't like i think
somewhere in the middle
okay
somewhere in the middle like i think
i think
if people are not hit people are not
really listening so i think people i
think what he's trying to say was
but the difference between
her um
michaela peterson and what was that a
girl's name
um yeah michaela peterson that's her
name
and the other girl who's
comparing her to
uh casey anthony casey anthony was who
she was yeah
i think he wasn't actually trying to
compare them
but the situations were somewhat similar
okay
similarities to this situation
the only difference is i think one
decided to
terminate terminates the pregnancy and
the other ones have to keep the
pregnancy
yeah okay yeah
um
i think things are showing
basically but i think both parties were
like
both parties were because how old is she
like 29 30
yeah yeah i think she's 30. i think she
just turned 30.
wouldn't be deemed as like the
epiphany
um i think it's around 27 to 35
i think
like
that
so that means that this is somewhere in
the middle of it
yeah yeah yeah
i don't think he i i don't think he came
off too harsh
i just think the way he communicated was
a little
was a little uh aggressive
was a little aggressive that's what i'm
saying i don't think what he's saying
was a little too harsh
i think i think his way off was like
um
a little aggressive i watched rolo
i watched him quite a lot
i watched a lot do you think you'd feel
that same way that he was being harsh if
um she was a he like if it was a dude
there
yeah
you would okay
um
because i actually
i think i think people would have a very
different reaction if it was a dude
in my opinion like i think part of the
reason that like people had the
reaction they sort of did was because
she's like a pretty female
yeah she agreed
the one where she went on uh
the
cafe
podcast yeah yeah yeah
yes oh like i think they're a little bit
just happy disingenuous
just a little bit
do you think that
um the roommates are a tad bit bit
disingenuous or i'm a tad bit is
disingenuous
okay the roommates this was happening
like
it was more of the way he was describing
how men flocked to the red tail how
about how their hate and all of that
about how they just hurt and going on
lines are doing that which is somewhat
true it's somewhat true when men get
hurt
towards the internet why do women do
this why she do this to me something
like that but they can always be
like for me
yeah to me when i was watching
will you see that again
i found my wrestler by accident i was
stumbling on youtube what was it
i ended up watching it
yeah well to me the roommates were it
was kind of like i just felt like they
talked about nothing
like they were just talking about the
sector of the red pill which is like in
cells
and like their trolls but like that's in
any movement there's going to be insults
and trolls for the most part like for
the most part
yeah
okay well i'm gonna go to the next
person but i appreciate you calling in
all right
have a good one
okay let's see
hello
hello can you hear me
yeah i can hear you yeah how are you
doing
yes i am yes you can talk about my
accent yeah
yeah yeah so yeah so i'm gonna go with a
country opinion i think uh don't get me
wrong there are things that michaela has
done that you know
fits this stereotype of obviously
you reach the epiphany phase you know
you find god and um and some of the
actions that she's done has not been
great but
i do think roller went too far and i'll
tell you why he's gone too far it's a
bit like if i saw rolo and i put the
thumbnail i don't know if you're
familiar with the person called jimmy
savile
with wait
say that again sorry are you familiar
with someone called jimmy savile
no i don't know who that is okay he was
a infamous uh pedophile who used to work
for the bbc
he he died obviously his crimes his
historic historical crimes against
children were revealed after he died now
if i had gotten their thumbnail with
jimmy savile and let's say um rolo on a
thumbnail and say the similarities no
one's going to believe the point i want
to disclaim as i said i'm not saying
that rollers like jimmy assemble but i'm
just saying that similarities what's
going to happen the human brain will
associate both of them and that's the
mistake and that's the manipulation that
rolo did but you realize you realize
that rollo didn't use um casey anthony
in his thumbnail
but he's not compared to
i to me it it wasn't like to me it
wasn't a comparison of saying these are
directly alike if he says yeah this is
the same dynamic that happened with this
girl it's the kill to party dynamic this
happened with this celebrity that
celebrity in that song yeah but you know
what's happening it's a wait can i
finish um it's also happening with this
celebrity
so to me it's like if he's saying this
is a dynamic this isn't the same exact
thing
and he's clarifying the whole time
the entire time he's saying like this is
not the same thing i know that she does
not actually want to kill her child it's
just the same thing that happened in a
different way like to me like we can all
understand what he's saying do you
disagree with that i
i mean if you're talking it from it if
it was a purely intellectual endeavor
fair enough but do you know how the
internet is you know
but rolo's platform is intellectual
if rolo if rolos it was strictly about
entertainment he could have monetized
this a different way a long time ago he
would be like roasting women and that
sort of thing his whole thing is
intellectual yeah but that's what's
talking about but let's face it now
let's be intellectually on this that's
what he mostly does talks he's so boring
for the last three hours and stuff all
it talks about female nature this nature
this nature
and for me what my issue is i'm not
saying that some of the stuff he doesn't
say in the rational mail doesn't make
sense there's some good things about it
and for men to be aware of but at the
same time if you're not talking about
okay what's the next step if you're just
going to tell me what's supporting
certain people right okay what i thought
was any different from you from a
radical feminist i said these are the
thoughts of men
and this is where i think if people need
to grow up you can't eat you can't
what's happening is that if you use that
to use an analogy is telling
these young
men to feed on milk but not
oh wait oh sorry i didn't mean to do
that yeah
are you still there sorry
on accident okay sorry don't worry
what it is that he's still feeding these
these guys on milk instead of migrating
them to to meet you see because
obviously he's got an example he's been
married for 25 years surely you should
be telling okay this is the sort of
woman you should be looking for this is
the um this is what you should do to
keep her these are the people you should
filter out that's fair enough that's
graduating i mean at the end of the day
don't be stuck on level one and that's
my issue with uh
well he does say that women are better
men and women are better together yeah
he says that all the time and he also
says that like you have to like a great
wife like you have to make like you have
to like i want to say train her but i
don't think he says those words exactly
so i think i'm paraphrasing i mean
there's a degree to culture and i agree
with that to certainly agree but i just
feel like yeah point is stuck in this is
level
one stuff and i just think come on it
gets boring after a while yeah i don't
know
i don't know if you watch don and don
john now what's his name
yeah
i think i was on their show a couple
months ago but no i haven't watched them
in a while yeah i think i think he's
spot on when he summarizes i call him
rollo polo at the moment at the moment
i
i do think a lot of the time red pill
focuses on like it doesn't focus on
solutions so i definitely agree with
exactly exactly
yeah i'm with you there i just i think
like
i in my opinion he doesn't he always
says if you come to this channel i'm not
selling you solutions
so there's a million solution channels
you can find he says look it
i'm just i'm just the messenger guy
yeah but that yeah yeah that roller's
been intellectually dishonest he's
having his cake and eat it what's the
part they are writing these these rules
and these books and so i've got offer
solutions come on be a man about it and
be or be on to what you say don't start
playing games
wait i'm just sorry i'm just confused
how is he what's not being a man by
saying he's not the solution guy that's
not no
he says in his book the rationale he has
these rules about what you should do but
he says i don't offer prescriptions i
mean come on
oh you're saying like that's that's
disingenuous because yeah exactly
okay exactly that's and that's why i've
got the pro that's why i've got the
issue with it you know stop saying have
your cake anita you complain about you
know
women don't say what they mean and blah
blah blah but you're acting the same way
and you're supposed to be the rational
male tell us men want to have it
straight not play silly intellectual
games and stuff so that's my issue with
rolo quite frankly
okay
okay well i appreciate the um this was
an interesting conversation so i
appreciate you calling in
no word
thank you bye
um okay i was this is the reason i had
to end that number one sandra thank you
for becoming a member thank you so much
number two
thank you for the two dollar donation
guys even if it's two dollars i
appreciate it so much the pregame is
going to be my new podcast and i am so
excited it is going to be so good i'm
trying to raise another thousand dollars
why i need a sound board and and four
more mics
four more
it's gonna cost about a thousand dollars
i'm at about like 200 ish
torsha then do call in
okay hello
hi
hi did you just get become a member
yes i did
thank you i you were i didn't even know
girls watched my channel of course we do
honestly i felt um the way you conducted
yourself on other manosphere channels
was very um classy and
i have i
think myself that i am kind of an
intelligent woman so it's kind of nice
to watch another you know intelligent
woman carry themselves in a very classy
manner you know so oh thank you you're
making me blush thank you
um so what so what do you think with
rolo too far yes or no
so i am actually a v-loma i don't know
if you know what that means
i do not know viloma means out of order
out of sequence so an orphan is a child
without parents a diloma is a parent
without their
child um i'm coming from the sense of
i've lost a child i've outlived a child
there was an accident out of babysitters
i don't want to go into it
but
i feel like guy or girl
kids are off limits man parenting
i feel is off limits you don't you have
absolutely no idea what's going on
behind closed doors
and you know i have seen
because i live kind of on the west coast
where it's a little different
where you have these guys who are out
you know drinking at the bar and having
beers and they're complaining about how
their baby mama is such a [ __ ] but it's
like you're out drinking a beer where's
your baby mama at right now
she's at home taking care of your child
and so with a lot of men like what i get
really irritated with with the
manosphere is i do believe that men
should be the leader i don't believe
that men and women were meant to be
equal to each other we were meant to
complement one another
there are certain things that we can do
that men can't and there's certain
things that men do that we can't however
i think when it comes to living your
life as a leader
you have to hold yourself to the same
standard that you hold everybody else to
because if you hold yourself to a
different standard than what you say
hold your wife to or hold your
girlfriend to or whatever then to me
that's not so much leadership it's
dictatorship you make your own rules for
yourself um so could i just understand
like what specifically you're talking
about with like rules for myself but not
other people
um okay so like or for him maybe i don't
know okay so like here's the thing like
as a single dad you know what i mean or
or like parents that don't have their
children all the time like if a dad went
out
on a yacht with his boys for a week
while mom was at home taking care of the
kids who would bat an eyelash at that
so it's like and and i'm coming from the
perspective of like while i wasn't a
parent for very long
like it's hard it's super hard and and
the stress that you go through and you
know it's around the clock it doesn't
stop you know and especially for
if you're not the primary
um parent or like you know you don't
have primary custody of your child like
you have to understand that it's very
rare that that other parent probably
even gets a second to themselves i mean
there's there's parents that don't even
get to take you know go to the bathroom
by themselves
so
it's like
if hey you're not a parent you really
shouldn't be thinking that way in the
first place and be if you're not there
raising your child and they're all that
much
then i don't feel like you really have
the right to judge just because somebody
else needs a break i think that parents
that
take breaks it's actually very healthy
because in if you think about it you're
getting yourself right and getting
yourself 100 and you're getting yourself
at a at a decent stress level so when
you go back to that child it's not as
insane and i'm not talking about the
woman that goes out and parties every
single weekend and her kids in a soiled
diaper i'm not talking about women that
are just irresponsible like that yeah
yeah no no i actually um
i don't think michaela really partied as
much as they made it seem to be honest
just like just like watching her content
i'm sure she did a little bit
but i think the dynamic is more like
like the kind of feeling of missing out
when women become parents young and i
know my mom kind of
went through that a little bit because
she had kids young but like she just
didn't divorce my dad
and maybe i just feel like it um a
little bit differently because when i
was in the
mid-20s that's when i had my son and it
was the most
fulfilled i had ever felt in my life and
yeah you know like a lot of the women
that say oh well i don't want kids like
girl you don't know what you're getting
yourself into and you know my son's been
gone for a couple of years now and i
can't even begin to tell you how badly i
want to be a mom again
yeah that's that's so i'm so sorry that
is so sad like my mom always says her
worst fear is to like outlive um or
outlive her kid so i can't even imagine
oh believe her and that's why like i
definitely feel like at least some of
the the mana sphere points are are fair
like you know especially when they like
when when they talk about how women are
claiming that they don't want to have
kids like ladies that's a trap like you
do and it's it's awful but
one thing that i do give a little bit of
pushback about is i grew up in a
household where both of my parents
worked both of them had to have jobs to
be able to pay bills
so while there's a lot of these you know
gold digging chicks in miami or whatever
you got to understand that a majority of
women have watched both their parents
work and both of their parents pay bills
so for me
i always assumed that my husband or
whatever is gonna expect me to have a
job is gonna expect me to pay some bills
that's it was actually the same for me i
didn't even like think about i'll joke
about like being a stay-at-home wife or
whatever but i didn't even think about
that as an option growing up because my
mom always worked
and that's also not to dispute that if
given the opportunity to stay at home oh
i would for sure at least until kids are
older but
you know not to dispute that point but
that's just always what i thought was
the norm and i feel like you know 80 of
america does not make over a hundred
grand a year and even if you do make a
hundred thousand dollars a year but
you're living in california it's really
like 60 grand a year so
a majority of americans a majority of
women a majority of men do actually need
to pay attention to how much money their
significant other makes
um so your your opinion on the situation
is like kids should just always be out
of it when it comes to like the internet
absolutely
okay okay that's a fair argument
i appreciate you calling in sandra
welcome to my memberships thank you i
appreciate you for having me
have a good one bye
bye
she was cool
i love it when girls call in i never i
was like is that a female
that's not torsia
never what do you guys think do you
think kids should be off limits
but here's here's oh i shoulda i didn't
think of this when she was on here's the
problem though how else would we ever
discuss single moms
because i don't really think he was
talking about the kit he was more
talking about like the dynamic
but that could be kind of traumatizing
for a kid
what do you guys think
let me know in the chat what do you
think also i believe i saw a donation
the five dollars um there's i will
read off any donation by the way there's
different stores for different products
not every store it has to be a walmart
for everything there are furniture
stores grocery stores
yes i agree i agree
torsha you should call in
rolo you should call in actually
um
oh my gosh
um
she put her life out there
um i mean that's a fair point
that's a fair point i actually but but
the kid didn't put her life out there
right
the kid did not
like she didn't choose that scarlet it's
not a bad argument
it's not
um
um you think torso and pearl are feds oh
my god i am not i have too big of a
mouth to be in the fed do you think the
fabulous on a [ __ ] with a youtube
channel
[Laughter]
um
okay what about
kids well because her argument is that
like kids should just stay out of it
like it's not fair to the kids the kids
didn't ask to be a part of this so like
if i was a child
would i be cool if i'm talking about my
mom like this
but on the other hand when you're a
public figure you forfeit you're right
but that's your right to privacy
your kids
your kids
fun fact when i do this people can like
see into my apartment and i can't see
them so sometimes i'm like
i have no one's out there um anyways
it's not about the child
see that that's a good point too
i have to think about this a little bit
more
i have to think about this because
you're right it's not about the child
it's about michaela
right like
the whole
thing it's about michaela would i sell
my eggs
for
what is that ten thousand a hundred
thousand yes
ten thousand probably not
i've heard selling your eggs is like a
lot of work like a lot of work
huh okay people call in one second
why
rolo
it's about hypergamy
and that's the problem
the child is a big deal to men and when
women said it's not it's about the kid
right because how could we have this
conversation at all without talking
about children because you're always
going to use an architect type of like
famous people like literally always
always always always like famous people
are
the archetype right
so i hear the argument about keeping the
kid out of it
understand it that makes sense to me
but
at the same time when you're a public
figure
i don't know i don't know
let's see fresh and fit michaela's
tonight
rolo's here call in rollo
call in
um
she needs to get her dad to battle rollo
i would pay i would pay to watch a
debate between jordan peterson and rolo
tomasi i would pay
um
should kids be left out of the
conversation call in but how else would
you have a conversation about single
moms
i don't know
i'm like i'm kind of on the fence about
that part
overall though he said the whole
broadcast he said i am not saying
i am not saying
that she
it wants to kill her kid we're talking
about a dynamic and to me like that
communication was so clear
so clear
31 likes and 44 viewers guys
guys
let's get me to 40 likes come on help
help a [ __ ] out
help a [ __ ] out
um
you think michaela is a four i would say
that she's like
an eight to be honest
i think that she's pretty enough to
model
um
or seven i actually think she is a seven
but
and then she's got a kid so what does
she lose two
um
i think she's very pretty but i also
i don't know i think blonde girls are
very pretty
oddly
uh she isn't ugly but i don't think
she's model level she looks pro bloated
she's a five six in my book
well i think she's only a five six
because
of the kid
i think she's a seven to be honest but
this is remember the average girl
is 150 pounds so the average girl is
overweight
come on guys let's raise it lemonade bae
i am pleasantly surprised by your
moderating abilities
okay guys as you guys know i am trying
to
do a podcast called the pre-game what is
the pregame i am going to bring girls
from my college
hot girls
okay hot not crazy girls
i have a girl on my team that's engaged
i have a girl on my team that's for the
streets and i have a girl on my team
that's in a long-term relationship we
can talk about all of it all of it on
the podcast
150 at like five five um
i think five four is the average height
for a girl
we can talk about everything everything
so
what does that mean
right now i have the equipment i have
four mics
and a sound board that hopefully will
get here tomorrow
it's late and i'm a little bit salty but
we'll see
then a second sound board and a second
set of mics i'm at about
210
dollars 210.
thank you guys thank you so much i
appreciate it so much
you all keep me going you keep me going
my goal is to get to a thousand i know
that's a huge goal i know we're not that
close to it
but
the reason
i think we can get it is because i think
this podcast i'm a hard worker you guys
i this is my third time streaming today
i work so hard
and i will put on a great show i i swear
to god i'll put on a great show you guys
give me the money to do this i will put
on a fantastic show for you you guys can
help me pick the topics every week i'm
gonna go on what you guys want what you
guys want to talk about we'll talk about
um okay
so that's my elevator pitch
um so we're at like 210 ish
don't be so materialistic i'm being
highly objective she's not my ideal
standard of beauty but your mom shapes
that for you
oh that's interesting
how do i know my friend is for the
streets
i don't like it i was just i was just
talking to be honest um there's a lot of
girls on my team i'm sure one of them is
for the streets um
her face looks swollen
lauren suther's personality makes her
two out of ten pearl puts out for cash
i do not i do not i don't even put out
okay you think aoc is a nine or ten
y'all are nuts
she's like uh i would put her at like a
six
i will put her at like a six
also
if you're watching my live and you're
not subscribed we have beef right now
like for real beef
because i don't know how you could watch
this fire ass show right now and not be
subscribed
i don't even breathe during these i just
talk talk talk look
do i ever catch myself using my
hypergamy filter yeah i want a guy
taller than me
isn't that hypergamous
that's my herpergamy
if someone drops 20
torsion will call
in people in the manosphere have very
high standards i don't know where you
live must be supermodels on the streets
look
jan
it's kind of like
you have to
put things in take things with a grain
of salt in the mana sphere
at first when you watch it you're like
oh my god these men are crazy they talk
about everything being wrong with women
but like in real life guys aren't as
picky as you think to be honest
39 likes one more like guys get me to
40.
get me to 40.
i'm sorry i think if michaela peterson
walks into most rooms outside of like
hollywood and maybe a major city
she's going to be one of the top like 20
prettiest girls in there
sorry
sorry
oh god
torsha that was 20 so that is
200
and thirty dollars total we have raised
for
the board
for the um
for the four mics and the sound board
230 dollars i could not do it without
all of you people all of you [ __ ]
respectfully
i say that as a term of endearment
endearment
um
lol make it a hundred and she'll video
chat in 100 bucks torsional video chat
100 bucks guys 100 bucks she'll video
chat in
um
oh my god
guys okay this is what we're not gonna
do we're not gonna talk about
we're we're not gonna
hold on hold on hold on
um
twenty dollars for a call-in
a hundred for a video call
what is it really oh i just felt like we
don't need to argue about like who's
prettier in the chat it's like awkward
guys like you know how awkward it is
when i'm just like
chilling with my friend and people are
like who's prettier in the chat like
guys we're both baddies get out of here
get out of here
um
it's not i'm not trying to fight it's
just like yeah like i don't
um
would be cool to get you torsha and miss
and ms peterson on the podcast at the
same time
it would
torsh's phone is calling i i hope she
didn't bamboozle you guys call in oh my
gosh
all in
girls girls you're both pretty i know
look at
i'm a baddie alright like
um
every day
no don't yeah don't call in if you've
already called in like that's not my
point isn't to call
for the same people
um
pearl's the only woman who i know can
pull off rubber bands oh my god i had
all the videos when i have rubber bands
are very old like they're very old like
a year old but oh my god i had braces
for like
two years
it was terrible i hated my life um
as an adult
it's worse than in high school you're
the only one
um
you're gonna hate the day when pearl
gets too big to read the chat
god i hope that day comes soon i'm so
poor
um
i'm so poor please
how is paris i'm in london and i love
london um
oh my god guys
pearl you are far from being a baddie
okay guys
here's what we don't need
i don't i don't need you arguing about
how attractive i am in the chat i don't
it's not up for debate this is how i
look um
okay
i thought you visited paris paris was
fun it was very fun
oh my goodness um
i should mod you
i need to make better life decisions
what i don't even
have i made bad i'm not pregnant like
i think i've made decent life decisions
um
but call in let me know honestly
where where have i gone wrong but keep
your camera on
um
new mic yeah i did get a new mic this
one is less good but it's like better
for
podcasting
uh yes you should get a bit invisalign i
think for men like women one of the
first things we notice is teeth for me
anyway
um
[Music]
okay another question
i i still i understand what that woman
that called in that was such a sad story
my heart strings um
was saying like kids should be left out
of it but i'm gonna be honest i
i think if you put yourself in the
public figure like that's just what
happens
and
if you don't want your kids to be
involved you don't have to post them
like no one even has to know they exist
second thing
um i thought it was height
well i meant like after well for me it's
hype but i'm also like a tall ass [ __ ]
i'm not the norm
most girls i think like five ten it's
like
decent um
what if my teeth are kind of straight
and not yellow but not white
i mean try to get them lighter if you
can't that's like all you can really do
there's like whitening strips why don't
you just buy those
um
how tall am i i'm like 5 11 and a half
guys we're getting off topic here this
isn't this isn't question pearl
we're trying to talk about michaela
peterson and rola tomasi
so call in let me know what you think
i'm gonna get more water though i'm
gonna be right back
i'm gonna be right back also
if you hear weird sounds my dog snoring
the sound board is for
donations will be
will go towards the soundboard and what
is the soundboard
the soundboard is going to host four
mics so that way i have four mics now
and i'll have four more
then i'll have eight and then i can do a
podcast which i'm going to call the
pre-game
and the pre-game is going to be about
different relationship topics that we'll
talk about some red pill some just fun
you know like what do you look for in a
guy look punch it you know
um
anyways if you think he was tough on her
i'm gonna put this link in the chat i'm
gonna go get water so like stay
entertained while i go get water
um i'm wearing really short shorts don't
look
okay wait
oh no okay
okay
nobody guys there's like 39 of you
there has to be one person that wants to
call in
oh yay
oh
someone called in i was about to add him
then he left guess not
you haven't finished this video yet
torsha but you saw the original you saw
the video with rolo tomasi
and michaela
like you saw that's the only video that
we need to talk about
roommates didn't really add anything
to be honest it was just like
the internet's angry there's in cells
okay
you know all the guys that always tell
me i'm gonna die alone always have no
profile pictures
i don't want to say it don't want to say
it
that was mean even for me pearl
was it true though was it true though
was it
oh god
oh my god
you know what's weird i don't even fully
consider myself red pill
royale was biased in theory michaela was
underprepared oh my god she was so under
prepared i was like i will coach you
ma'am
if you need help before the next
interview i will coach you
i will coach you
sometimes i think it would have been
better if she was just like
yeah
i did party a little bit in my mid-20s
someone was watching her
so what
it doesn't mean i was a bad mom
do you have an ice machine in the uk i
think that would have been a better
response um
do i have an ice machine in the uk no i
have a nice tray
oh my god ellie
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god it smells
um i don't torsha i'm hearing a lot of
excuses here um
thank you so much for the super chat
says you're not gonna die alone you're
such a cool person
thank you also your first the first and
only super chat i will ever do
i'm so excited to be your first um i
think that puts us
at like 2
15-ish
i'm very bad at counting i think i'm at
like 215 out of the thousand dollars or
225 i can't remember which
i'll go back and look later but thank
you thank you very much again the goals
a thousand dollars
it's going to cover
the mics
um
huh
oh yay
what up
hey what's up
how are you
i'm good how are you
good
so what's your opinion
did what do you what do you call rollo
rolo what about i thought you had like a
nickname for him
yeah did your baby daddy take it too far
so i haven't finished the video yet
but i actually was surprised at how
pleasant it was for the first half at
least it wasn't me at the end yeah
it wasn't me did you watch the original
one he made about michaela like a while
ago
the
hypergamy one wait which one yeah the
one where he he says like the he talks
about michaela in the kill to party
dynamic
oh yeah
did you think he took it too far because
he kind of made a comparison to the kids
yeah because that's what michaela was
mad about in the interview and on the
roommates podcast was
she was saying like
that that was an unfair comparison that
he shouldn't have made that well that's
easy to jump to
when your feelings are hurt i guess like
how i put it
i know that sounds bad so let me
you know it's so funny because if i find
that it's gonna sound bad it's usually
because there's another woman listening
like like not you but i'm saying like if
she were to see it it's like you don't
want to be mean in a gynocentric social
order to women because it will be
sounding mean same thing when it comes
to
trans arguments if you don't like
something it's usually okay they're
transphobic and it's like no i just
don't want
anything in legislation that would tell
me what to say to somebody so i was just
talking about that that's off topic but
my point is like
using her as like a placeholder or
like comparing somebody to somebody that
murdered their kid it's an easy thing to
argue like why that was wrong
that's like a cop out i don't know
no i i agree with you i think he said so
many times in the stream i am not saying
that she wants to kill her kid like he
said that
at least five times and i'm like did you
not hear him
yeah no
and that's what
that's what bothered me and i kind of
hate when people say that's what
bothered me about this because my
feelings don't matter just as much as
her feelings don't matter in the sake of
an argument
i'm not saying that like on a personal
level i would be mean to her it has
nothing to do with that it's just
showcasing this dynamic of hypergamy and
how even the kill the party like getting
there but with hypergamy specifically
it's showcasing women's behavior and
sometimes it's not it's not nice it's
not comfortable to hear it when um shout
out to the girl that called in uh
earlier who joined your memberships um
she she brings up an important point and
i'm gonna say it's important because
it's i i hope she watches this and
because i when we find things like i
don't think we should bring kids into it
i encourage you as a viewer like as a
woman too to see it as well is that
coming from a place where it kind of
takes my bad behavior out of the
equation you see like women will try oh
that's interesting that's a good point
yeah yeah and i'm not saying she's doing
that intentionally and i'm not saying
that she's doing that from a bad place
i'm saying it as like it's coming from
it it's coming from trying to
move with modern times with the old
order you know roll it always says like
you will order rules but old order
thinking
and
listen i like empathize and sympathize
with women because it's like you're
trying to
navigate this thing
in dating like you're trying you don't
understand maybe that there's two maybe
more meeting strategies going on so you
might think that what you're you've
always gone for beta males you might
think that but in reality
they were out of your league
and it's like i've dated some ugly ass
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
talking about you know but to some
capacity
they were out of my league and that
takes a lot of introspection and being
able to be like what are my toxic
behaviors because it's on a deeper level
than i think people get but anyways when
you use when you say well i think we
should take kids out of it that's fine
then don't go to divorce court and
expect
to get preferential treatment don't
expect to be the what do you call it
like the um
i forget the word when you're like the
one with the most custody
what do we call that
um
um i can't think of the name but i know
what you're talking about yeah i i know
what you're talking about i know what
you're talking about so it it's more so
that and you know she might be thinking
i'm trying to see it from like all
angles and i don't have a kid so that's
the thing is like for me
to say that it it's going to come off
harsher and i listen i'm all for
moms like seriously i think single moms
sometimes you know people want to hate
on them but you know what they're
increasing our birth rate more than
anyone else so
kept that going you know like everybody
yeah yeah
so like when i say i know it's really
easy to like go in those directions i'm
just trying to see it from a society
standpoint because we all want to say
you know my situation's different or you
know it's different in each city but the
problem is when we live in in the us or
just any country and we're so globalized
there's no point in addressing those
anecdotal experiences or there's no
point in saying well it's different in
this city because the problem is the
message is out there for everybody and
if somebody wants to argue with me that
women were not taught
that
like okay pearl i'll ask you this
it's so cold in my courage um
i remember vividly
being taught at a young age that when
i'm ready to have kids
i'll be ready i'll probably be in my 30s
and that was like a thing i don't know
if i'm trying to figure out if like it
was so insidious that i could find what
programs came to the school to actually
see what exactly they were teaching but
with my memory remembering that
specifically i'm like okay and i'm like
going through all the ages throughout
school and i'm like yeah like when you
see that feminism was
like really infiltrated in the education
systems because women are more teacher
more teachers are women and women want
you to well and and they subsidize
education so like there's no incent like
there's no incentive to do a better job
because they're still going to get the
students regardless so if people
complain there's no
right that's because that's when a lot
of this stuff happened was in the 19 i
want to say 60s when they subsidized
education no it did but but i went to
catholic school so they
so they they taught they taught us to
wait till we were married they didn't
say to get married but i'm assuming
that's like an implication that's what i
wanted to do to be honest
yeah no it it's absolutely a thing when
it comes to religion too and it's
interesting that you bring up that point
because i've been talking a lot about
how we've kind of dissolved religion and
we're trying to
say well my feelings matter if you do
this like that's wrong it's like but who
is it wrong to the individual so why are
we trying to and this gets really into
like legislation and that's more so
where i find issues and that's why i
talk about the society it's like you
can't really
say
well this city it's different it doesn't
matter anymore it doesn't matter it's
all on well i think i think the reason
people say that like the city the city
is different is because like when when
you're constantly being bombarded with
girls on fresh and fit like every single
day you're watching that podcast like it
seems like people think like
like women are a lot more hypergamous
than they really are
because like i don't know about you but
my friends like maybe you want a guy
that makes a little more money that's a
little older a little taller but it's
not crazy it's not it's not like insane
which like that girl that called in on
my show like i've never heard a girl
talk like that in my life
well that's a problem too because both
you and i were on fresh and fit
so when we say the girls on fresh and
fit i
i think it's wrong for a and i see it a
lot that people group the girls like
they're some they objectify them and i'm
not talking about like
like people actually in that room i'm
talking about like well just the hose on
freshen day and it's like okay sorry
sorry the the the hoes that go viral are
typically pretty ratchet the girls that
go viral on fresh and fit
there there's exciting
like who um
like any like google okay
i know i know the girl you're thinking
of i know which one you're the one that
dated somebody who's like
uh that's the only one i go up that goes
viral
unfresh and fan no i'm saying like
you you see ratchet girls go viral all
the time or it's like martin tells girl
the truth or this girl walks off or this
girl does like like you see that stuff
all the time i don't know their names
because they're just like
to me like bimbo one bimbo tube and both
like but see that's that's the mentality
that i think
what i'm trying to get it is like people
already assume that because what they
look like and what they talk like and
what they say on a show in front of a
camera
is true now
we like to go into it thinking people
are being honest they're gonna their
[ __ ] will get
exposed if they're not right but the
problem is that people will
automatically assume in and i see this
all the time in arguments well those
girls on brush and set they're bimbos
they're hoes whatever you want to say
like i've done it too i'm not saying
that i've gotten away with this it's
something i've been thinking about and
i'm like you know that's like a cop-out
because i know that i'm not a hoe you're
not a hoe you know you're not a hoe and
so it's like i can only imagine all the
women
that are on that show that weren't hoes
but what they all have in common
because in order now correct me if i'm
wrong rolo brought me on the show so i
kind of have that loophole but i'm
pretty sure from what they say on the
shows i've seen you have to submit
your insta or your whatever to see what
they look like that's common in my
industry and bartending you have to be
attractive it's just send the instagram
so i i get it but when you think about
okay why do why do women have instagram
why do women want to go on the show okay
you can assume they probably want the
attention right to some so somebody and
you have to realize like it's girls
during the week that are
available till like four or five in the
morning
like what what target it's like girls
without a job i mean you know granted
i'm one but
but like
like what i'm saying like when i worked
in sales there were like a million girls
that were just like normal like that
just like worked at the company in
different branches right they would
never be able to go on a show like that
because like on the weekends
they'd probably be hanging out with
their friends and during the week like
they're not about to stay until four or
five in the morning and i don't think
it's a cop-out
to say that the girls on freshman fit
tend to be wilder than in real life
especially
i said i don't think it's a cop-out to
say that the girls on fresh and fit tend
to be wilder and more hoey than in real
life the girls that i see day to day
because the ones
where did i cut off where did i cut off
you literally cut off the entire the
entire thing the last thing that i heard
was uh four o'clock five o'clock in the
morning and like
wait say your point again i'm so sorry
no it's okay it's okay there there tends
to be like girls that go on there that
are available under like until like four
or five in the morning
that's so late okay
i yeah because i don't know when i went
on i was there until like four or five
in the morning
yeah
we got off
maybe two
no it was so late it was so late when i
went but okay fine even two or three
okay let's do two or three on a weekday
like their show was during the week and
on weekends like like when i think of
girls that i know that are pretty normal
i think of like
girls i went to college with or like at
my sales job okay
they wouldn't be available because they
all have have jobs and like things to do
but
that's that's where i think it's
it's wrong because one we went in during
like the summer
and most girls that work the nine to
five are off on fridays and get out
early i here's the here's the job titles
i've heard like legal assistant
i remember that girl
um and i've heard uh what do you call it
when you type out stuff when you're in
the courtroom you know i've heard a
multitude of like
different jobs because then you know you
got your strippers you got those girls
with a lot of disposable income whatever
but it's not the job and like okay okay
let me let me ask you this question
that's sampling i'm trying to finish the
point from okay okay
like people
will go in with a virtuous lens and be
like well those girls don't matter
because they're hoes and it's like okay
whatever your definition of a hoe is
which me and donovan have clarified this
i remember somebody called in it was
funny but it's like a woman that sleeps
around uh it's a woman that
apparently sleeps around with everybody
all the time that's what i took from it
i was like i just thought a hoe was just
you know
like mo like
i don't want to say like [ __ ] photos
but somebody who seeks attention who's
also banging like a bunch of dudes or
using guys for money like it's an
all-encompassing thing for probably
immoral to some capacity but
my point is that people will disregard
and say well the girls i'm fresh and fit
are hoes that's fine but they all have a
hypergamous filter and it's all very
evident because even girls that i've
talked to when it's like let's say
your everyday girl do you want a guy
that's making less than you it's almost
unheard of because women typically do
marry up they want for sure for sure for
sure
for sure
no i i agree with you there wait are you
still there did you cut out hello
are you there
hello
pearl
yeah hi
there
i think she's cutting out
i'm lost
[ __ ]
are you are you back
yeah my phone might die sorry that's
probably why it's cutting out
no you're okay um what i was saying
though what i'm saying though is that
like i understand what you're saying
like the point is the hypergamous filter
and i'm with you i'm with you like i
understand what you're saying but what
i'm saying is like a sample size of
women on fresh and fit i don't think is
representative of like of the female
population or even close to it
i think i think miami is like
what
i think i heard what you said correct me
if i'm wrong but did you say i don't
think it's representative of majority
is that what you said of women or like
the other yeah like i said i don't think
it's an accurate like sample size like i
think when you get a sample size out of
miami that's like hypergamy on steroids
but i understand what you're saying like
like yes women are still hypergamous
i've never like
so no
yeah it's like what i'm saying like
really
but i'm saying like when girls when
girls say
that like oh it's the girl's unfresh and
fit what like what people are trying to
communicate is that that's not really
representative of like the female
population
like that's what people are saying i
don't think it's like a cop-out
right but i'm saying in terms of having
the discussion and say well let's say
that it's not just miami girls it's like
when they say that well those girls are
just hoes it cuts off the ability that
to have the conversation that was my
point was like we're so quick to jump to
say don't even think about this my point
with that was like yeah it was like with
the kids
you know we're gonna
don't bring the kids in it now you see
how when you say well those girls are
just hoes [ __ ] those it's like when
we're we say those things in
conversation we're cutting off the
opportunity to have the discussion so
it's better to include than this clue
does that make sense
yeah now i understand what you're saying
yeah it's like they're all examples of
hypergamy
yeah but it's more so as soon as we want
to tell people well don't use my kid
because that offends me i'm not saying
she said that i'm not at all but i can
see how other women will take it like
well we shouldn't use children but it's
like when you decide that children are
like exempt from the conversation you're
telling me that i
it
reminds me of like pronouns and
legislation i know this is a really
extreme example so hear me out but it
reminds me of well if they don't say
this to me then it's hate speech so
you're saying that if i were to bring up
the child i'm now
it's now hate speech on women with kids
i know that's a very extreme yeah no i i
i see that i see what you're saying no i
see the analogy
yeah no that makes sense to be honest
yeah
if mckayla didn't have a kid and we used
her in the dynamic let's say she didn't
have a kid but she had the fear of
missing out party component which you
know we don't think she's really that
big of a party animal but you know what
i'm saying it's like well
she would still would she still be
married to what's-his-face if they
didn't have the baby
because that's old order thinking and
she mentioned it in a video saying that
you know
they got pregnant and they're like okay
let's get married you know old order
thinking i don't think it's wrong but i
think what's wrong is you have a very
modern woman
trying to navigate old order thinking
and new order thinking and a lot of
women nowadays they're they're at least
the ones that i've talked to it's not
that many but that get the ma manosphere
thing it's it's always going to result
to well how do i make the past
disappear
well you could say don't use kids in the
conversation or but you know what i'm
saying so it's just one of those things
that people need to understand there's a
lot more going on when you see people
develop arguments it's usually coming
from a place of well i'm disappointed
that i did make this decision and i want
to kind of dissolve myself of it to some
capacity that's fine that's all i was
going to say i guess i don't know the
only the only count
no no the only counter argument i see to
that is like
i just think like that would be a hard
video to watch if you were the kid
what do you mean if the kid got older
and saw yeah yeah yeah then don't go on
any show and don't go on anything to
talk about this kind of stuff
you know what i'm saying right but it's
like almost like not really fair to the
kid because she didn't really make that
decision
like she she's just a kid
what do you mean make the decision the
mom
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
yeah i know but that's the mom's
decision not the kid again she needs to
be held to
like she needs to be the one that thinks
long term that's the problem we're not
right long term oh i'm here i'm with you
i'm with you like torsha i'm with you
like i'm a hunter no i know you are yeah
yeah like like we don't but i'm saying
like again that's not the kid's fault
that her mind right so the monster
but the mom shouldn't make short-term
decisions on behalf of the kid
like the mom shouldn't go on
and say that
if you don't want it to bite you in the
ass later because at the end of the day
you are responsible for all your
decisions
i'm a very individualism type of person
so
that might not go for everybody i know
other people think otherwise and that's
fine i just think that women
like want to jump on what feels weird
and short-term was the girls was the
girl's name dan jan were you the one
that called in earlier you should call
in again this would be fun
i don't know if she's still in the chat
but if you are call in again i know i
said not to but you're the i love jan is
it james
i think that's who she was i don't know
my girl love her like if you she poses
great
great
um
if it that that's who it is i see her
comment in my chance all the time and
she really poses
good arguments to uh
that really represent and i'm not saying
that jan is on the left or anything but
they pose
better questions that women will
ask
or like our community asks and so i i
think it's important to still have those
conversations and they i don't know she
always poses that really
respectfully the women the women who go
on podcasts might not even be a sample
of the general population anymore
because anyone shy or busy is removed
from the sample fresh infant is even
worse due to the scheduling and location
restrictions
oh never mind jan
i'm sorry
shared phone died
those are that was a good argument
that's a good discussion
guys send a donation in the chat
send a donation
send a donation in the chat
um
hold up um
torsh is pretty good no she has her own
channel you guys should go subscribe
it's pretty she's pretty entertaining
um
these kids too far let me know
will not send a donation i'm freeloading
at least you're honest
thank you
[Music]
thank you for the ten dollars i think
we're at like 2 30 for donations 230
dollars
my goal is a thousand my goal is a
thousand you guys already know it's for
the podcast that i'm launching
um
who do i love
um or what do i love i love playing
sports and youtube
pretty much
um i want to see something actually
um
huh
okay
that's an interesting argument though
that like we're looking to like absolve
women of responsibility by saying oh we
can't talk about the kids
because i'm trying to think of the male
what would the male equivalent of that
be
like would we have the same energy with
a guy
that's going out and partying
okay
and people are like
and dating 20 year olds and having like
a midlife crisis
and if we had a show saying batman's
having a midlife crisis
he's pretending
to i don't like something something
similar
do you think we would have
the same
energy that's the question
i think rolla was just because she
carries a kid like a shield or a trophy
or how good or bad her life
is going ever seeing a hypergamous man i
think men are hypergamous too i just
think they're more willing to like
settle and women will like never settle
ever
but no i think men like want the hottest
[ __ ] they can get
like the combination of like hot
personality and
whatever
like
i think whatever they value you know
agreeableness femininity like i think
they want the best combo they can get
is nick hamm at cannon having a midlife
crisis no he's living it up
no i think there's a lot of shame like
people roast him all the time for having
like a million baby mamas
um like that should be shameful you
should not get that many [ __ ]
pregnant that is not fair to the kids
sorry not sorry
um
well i'm not sure if jan was the girl
who called i i'm not positive
i'm i'm not i just
i just thought maybe
i don't know um
nick cannon is the king of no pull out
game absolutely that
that is what he does
um
oh let's see michaela
am i a roller disciple
not really i think he makes a lot of
sense though unfortunately it's kind of
annoying
like he's kind of a buzz kill if i'm
being honest like
like actually a buzzkill
um
hold on one second
um decided to make me a mod here as well
you can be
um let me see if i can do it
um
[Music]
just you guys know if you wild
one huge difference between men and
women is that if a dude scores a woman
way out of his league he's suspicious
women believe they deserve it
that's true
um where do you draw the line in between
female individualism and them being gold
diggers
i don't know that's a great question
i don't think it's money though i i
genuinely don't think that women are
attracted to money i think if a man if a
bum wins the lottery
i don't think he's automatically hot i
don't
but i think if i learn a guy as a ceo
and he's competent enough to be a ceo
that i'm more attracted to him but a
lottery winner it's not money it's
competence we are attracted to
competence
um
i shot once
saw
a show called the office that's the
first time i realized it was a girl's
name
money equals status
equals hot status oh absolutely when we
are absolutely attracted to status
it's very attractive like like seeing a
guy that gets along with other people
and other people like that is absolutely
attractive any girl that says that it's
not is lying
like seeing a guy like in his friend
group like getting along with people
and like people like liking him
i don't know
um
okay hold on
okay 8 30. um there are historical
amounts examples of men marrying rich or
more powerful women it was often seen as
an issue and they had to get prenups
i would get a prenup
i absolutely would i'm probably not
going to stay too much longer
so if you guys want to call in call in
now
lemonade bay i am so impressed with your
moderating skills
i am so impressed
shocked really
i was not expecting
um
you should do a reaction
to andrew tate on your mom's house
podcast
it's episode 636 send me the link to my
ig
just.purlythings i'll put it in the chat
we're professional mods i don't know
lemonade bay is a little bit of a troll
so i'm like
i was a little nervous but
he's a great mod great mod
um okay guys i'm gonna put the link one
more time anyone have any opinions about
rolo tomasi
did he take it too far
yes or no
was comparing
michaela peterson
to
that one chick that killed her kid even
though he said multiple times he said so
many times
it's not a direct comparison
i know she doesn't want to kill her kid
it's just the inconvenience of having a
kid
even though she said that
let me know in the chat let me know
i think she's shocked because i have a
reputation i have no idea what your
reputation is like at all um i don't
talk to torsha about this
also if you've been watching for a
second feel free to send a donation i'm
trying to
i appreciate every donation
or sign up for a membership
i have three members now one of them is
my mom i'm not gonna lie to you but you
could be number four
it could be you
he did push the boundaries um by making
that comparison he did he clearly did it
for click bait then tried to cancel it
in the video by saying it's not a direct
comparison i disagree
i disagree
i i think in the original video if you
watch the full thing he says so many
freaking times
so many times
i'm not saying
this is what i'm not saying that she
wants to kill her kid
and no matter how many times she said
that
i don't know i don't even think the
party phase is that big of a deal to be
honest like i'm not saying like
completely whole out and be like a
complete hoe
like definitely not i'd say you know
avoid sleeping with this you know sleep
with as little people as possible
don't be acting wild and don't go to
bars every weekend but like
i don't i don't think it's like crazy
knowledge that people tend to party when
they're younger
like
even if you said it 5 000 times it
doesn't really cancel that it's indecent
to use that as click bait
but i don't think he really used it as
clickbait because let's let me pull up
the video i'll pull up the video
um
rolo tomasi
mikayla
the original one let's see the original
oh i don't know that's the wrong podcast
hold on
um
i'm gonna share my screen
if you're gonna if you're gonna accuse
him of click bait
make sure you have your facts ma'am
respectfully like make sure you got your
facts
that is the thumbnail
kill to party michaela peterson
that girl is not what's her face casey
anthony
nowhere
nowhere in this clickbait
the only clickbait he really used it was
her hotness
and a photo that she put out
film and then when he said casey anthony
that wasn't clickbait because he said it
in the middle of like a three hour
stream
and when he's every time he said it he
clearly said
i am not saying that she wants to kill
her kid
i'm like as women like why can't we just
like
like
okay like we understand what he said
he's just referring to a dynamic so all
he was saying was
this is the kill-to-party dynamic an
example of this is casey anthony another
example of this is brittany renner
another example of this
is so-and-so right
and now michaela peterson is another
example
now i'm not saying that she wants to
kill her kid like i don't think that's
crazy i'm sorry i don't i don't
why make the comparison at all
because you have to use public figures
as examples of everyday life like who
else are you gonna use
it didn't
like like that that dynamic is very
clearly shown in the casey anthony
situation so that's why he used it i
mean are there other celebrities he
could have used yeah britney renner he
used like three it wasn't just her
i don't know
just my opinion the kids the the kids
argument i can see like leave the kids
out of it
i could see that but i don't know
torture was making a lot of sense
she was making a lot of sense
when she came on here
it's public it's free game that's true
um
i look like that girl from that 70s show
i wish
i would do anything to like literally
fix my jaw
i have jaw issues people
i'd literally do a lot
okay i see this i see this um this tweet
i turned 28 this week and whilst i'm
younger than many i've lived several
lives i was a 20 a degenerate drinker
once had to flee a city and the 24 hours
have worked in four countries and three
continents
built a business and i'm a married
father here's 28 lesson i was a
degenerate drinker two men have epiphany
phases i wonder if there's like a male
equivalent to this that nobody's made
maybe it'll be me
you think donna
oh my gosh i'm getting tired
okay guys
i appreciate you all for watching
i think that's
that's it for collins tonight so i'm
gonna end the show
i for real appreciate all the call-ins
appreciate the support i appreciate the
donations more than ever
and i will talk to you guys next time